la plus grande part à pharmacie de
france se trouve à one nation paris
outlet aux clayes-sous-bois soul
enseigne parapharmacie lafayette une
parapharmacie standard mais qui
proposent des produits alimentaires du
made in france du bio sans lactose sans
allergènes ou encore pour les personnes
vegan je suis étonné toute chose bio
qu'on trouve dans les magasins bio ça
c'est intéressant
l'accès aux produits alimentaires
spécifiques et de bien-être est
désormais et démocratiser une quinzaine
d' espaces leur sont consacrés dans
cette parapharmacie les français
consomment de moins en moins en
prêt-à-porter plus que 3 % de leur
budget alors qu'ils consomment de plus
en plus dans le monde de la santé du
bien-être avec des dépenses qui sont
multiplié par quatre sur les 40
dernières années donc une une forte
demande des consommateurs 51 salariés
dont 5 pharmaciens diplômés sont
présents dont 7 parapharmacie un
investissement global de 5 millions
d'euros en partenariat avec lafayette
quarante mille produits sont présentés à
prix bas jusqu'à 30 à 40% inférieurs à
ceux couramment pratiqué c'est la
conjonction d'un réseau qui est entre
ces pharmacies et parapharmacies fait
750 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires ce qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de pouvoir négocier avec les
laboratoires les meilleures conditions
possibles c'est aussi un e chef
d'entreprise qui va baisser ses marges
comme c'est beaucoup moins cher que les
gens vont venir je vais en vendre plus d
étiquettes électroniques permettent aux
clients d'obtenir dans la langue
souhaitée sur leur téléphone toutes les
informations sur le produit
la fréquentation est présente dans cette
parapharmacie outlet 4000 clients en
deux jours pour leur premier week end
c'est ce qui manquait en
dans le coin ça va vite et que en et
pharmacie avec une surface de 2100
mètres carrés la parapharmacie lafayette
para one est la plus grande part à
pharmacie de france